- HOW AM I EVER GONNA
FIND THIS COUGAR?
- FOLLOW THE DEAD GOATS.
- GOOD IDEA,
VOICE IN MY HEAD.
YOU SOUND SO MUCH COOLER
THAN WHEN I TALK OUT LOUD.
- IT'S ME, DUMBASS.
YOU PICKED THE WRONG TIME
TO START ACTING LIKE A MAN.
THAT COUGAR'S GONNA
EAT YOU ALIVE, STEVE.
- THANKS FOR THE TOUGH LOVE.
NAMASTE.
- "NAMASTE."
NAH, I'MA STAY RIGHT HERE
WHERE THERE AIN'T NO COUGARS.
[goat bleats]
- YOUR SUFFERING IS OVER.
MERCY IS UPON YOU.
[goat bleats]
UH, SORRY ABOUT THAT.
NOW, MERCY WILL BE UPON YOU.
[goat bleats]
ALMOST DONE.
YOU'LL BE WITH JESUS SOON.
[grunting]
DIE!
[goat bleats loudly]
SAVE A PLACE FOR ME
IN HEAVEN, FRIEND.
[boom]
THAT MUST BE
WHERE IT LIVES.
BE A MAN, STEVE.
[nervously]
BE A MAN, BE A MAN, BE A MAN,
BE A MAN, BE A MAN,
BE A MAN, BE A MAN.
[creature growling]
[screams]
I DON'T WANT TO BE A MAN!
[grunts]
DAD?
OH, MY GOD.
DAD!
IT'S YOU!
- [grunts]
- I HAVE ONE
QUESTION FOR YOU, DAD.
WHY DO I HAVE
A BALL-GINA?